first of all I want to start by saying
how much I loved the movie I was
fortunate enough to see it at Sundance
and it was one of my favorites and I'm
so happy it's getting a wide release in
just a few weeks and a moment that's all
I have no but I actually am curious it
for the two of you talk a little bit
about when you first met each other and
those and like that initial conversation
of because I know you're a huge fan and
I know you must be a fan but what is it
like the night before you're gonna meet
or talk are you in your head a little
bit like man I hope she likes me what a
great question well I was coming from
set and they said Emma Thompson's in Los
Angeles she almost never does this she's
going to a fancy dinner and before that
she's of fancy drinks you're not invited
to that but there's a window before the
drinks where she's at the hotel and
she'll just kind of be leaving and if
you can catch her in the hotel you can
have a conversation with her is what
makes me feel it's my job you pack your
trips you can't meet with some strange
Indian woman who wants to meet you so I
raced from set we were shooting the
Mindy project I raced from set and I had
an outlandish outfit on because I just
wore the costume not knowing what Emma's
deal was and she was like she might care
that I wear fancy clothes she didn't
he's not that kind of person but with
and I met her in the lobby of a hotel
and we we had a drink a quick drink
before other drinks and I was so excited
everybody in the cast and crew thought I
was meeting her and I had this great
feeling of them sending me off and like
good luck I never told you that but I
told everyone and everything yeah and I
work with EJ by then you had I was so
jealous mr. banks with BJ yeah and she
would tell me stories about her and then
she and Tom Hanks were such good friends
and everyone had such a great rapport
and I want to hear this anymore I'm too
jealous and so I think I found I got to
meet her and I where'd you read quite an
outfit on I do and I did think you were
a little bit weird because it was so it
was just you would yeah I thought also I
just didn't expect me myself in any way
to be relevant to something like Mindy
do you understand that I could feel that
but I said
just very surprised by all and then when
she said I've written something for you
I didn't know what to do with my face
but of course I then III said I'd love
to read it and thank you so much what
else I mean it was just it was a short
time I remember I had to go off to do
something and you were you were very
busy also because you were actually
working and I read it and 48 hours later
I said to my agent this script is one of
the best things I've read in years we
have to make it happen that first of all
it's a great story but second of all I'm
so happy that this meeting took place so
you're obviously a very talented writer
you're a very talented writer talk a
little bit about so you get the script
how much is it exactly what you got that
day how much are you sort of
collaborating a little bit because
you're both such great writers well I
was so welcoming of notes from Emma I
mean the character was written for her
and she had to be able to perform it but
also notes on other characters and she's
written so many screenplays so many
award-winning screenplays that I thought
lucky you don't often get to turn a
script into someone couldn't we really
admire normally you're giving getting
notes from people that you think are now
and so to be able to get notes from Emma
on the script was really lucky I can't
remember giving you notes on this I mean
no no we did talk about it and it did
change in some ways didn't live between
the moment we met and then three years
later when we actually got to shoot it
but I mean I just remember it being
brilliant and just right from the get-go
but I'm things always change screenplays
always change and I haven't written
loads of award-winning screenplays I
have written lots of screenplays some of
which haven't been made and one of which
won an award that's just a bit you know
just to be accurate you do have a new
movie coming out at Christmas though I
did right and you do have a talented
director doing that with Brian Cummings
here's a wonderful performance artist as
well who did our first draft and Paul
Feig yeah just throwing that out there
one of the things I really love about
the script is that it deals with a lot
of things going on today without it ever
feeling preachy and that's something
that I really admired so can you sort of
talk about that aspect that being able
to weave
all these culturally relevant things
without batting you over the head I
think um thank you for saying that
wouldn't that's really a nice compliment
and that's really what we are going for
with the film is to create a really
funny movie that's relatable and that
maybe you'll take away some themes or
ideas from it that make you look at the
world a little differently
thank you I think that the reason it
comes across that way is that no one is
acting out of character everyone is
acting in character
no one is it's not a documentary you
know it's we're not trying to preach
it's just the real details of what it is
like to come up in a business when you
are another and there's some parts of it
that are painful and there's some parts
of it that are really funny but it all
has to be real and you don't get to see
those stories that often and I've been
saying this too but the fact that M and
I are both the leads of the movie is in
and of itself kind of this political
strange statement because we're not you
don't see two women in a movie as leads
in a comedy movie where we're not you
know fighting over the same man you know
it's so but anyway but um
anyway yeah also I think it's important
to say that the reason these sort of
issues appear to be kind of because many
people have said this but it's actually
just because that's our experience
that's normal experience for women you
know the authenticity of it means that
watching Molly in that situation
watching Catherine that that's normal so
that's what happens in everyday life
it's not so so for us if you like it's
not issues it there they're there
they're not sort of political points
they're just what life is do you know
what I mean so it's the authenticity of
it that means that you can have access
to those thoughts you know 100 percent
you guys had the challenge of trying to
pull this off in 25 days I believe what
the hell was that like and we're never
doing it again no
I was gonna say what what talk about
that 25 days to pull this off and which
sequences were you like oh my god this
has never happened I mean you look at
the font of the movie it doesn't appear
to be an indie movie but it was it was
an indie movie we shot it for an almost
no money and in 25 days and this is a
movie that the script is not like a you
know quintessential indie script there's
a lot of characters it takes place in
New York City you have to see a fake
late-night talk show set that has to
look amazing
its immense dramatic stress you know
those are not things that you normally
see in an indie movie so it was
extremely difficult that hours are very
long
we shot yes the crew was incredible and
it's it meant a lot to get actors in the
movie like Amy Ryan and John Lithgow
Reed Scott John early those type of
actors to do this movie for no money
just because they liked the world and
wanted to be part of the project and
they was so great they brought so much
and everybody brought so much to it it
was created in a white heating in a way
it was our passion all our collected
passions for the script that made it
possible to do that you couldn't have
done the hours work that we did you know
in that way if you hadn't really just
loved it so much I mean I was so excited
to get to work every day every day to
just even if I was on my knees and knock
it I just I can't wait to say that liner
can't wait
ultimately I like talking about the
editing process because that's the final
rewrite so I'm very curious how the film
came together and the hell the film came
together there in the editing room maybe
how it changed what you learned from
early screenings yeah absolutely you
know we were lucky enough to have Dave
Rodgers who's an Emmy award-winning
editor from the office come and work on
the movie and he just I don't want you
know we didn't have a ton of takes know
for another thing but he's really used
to those big group scenes you know with
the the writers room and the in the
movie is not dissimilar than the those
big conference room scenes in the office
where you have to you know and that's it
you really have to build those things
you know a joke a reaction and where the
where the laugh is and so it was really
wonderful
seeing seeing his work on that and to go
in and steal extra jokes right ADR lines
to get you know extra jokes here and
there and yeah it was editing in comedy
is both is so challenging but it is so
rewarding as well I definitely have to
ask you have you noticed a newfound
popularity if you will on the office
since it's been on streaming definitely
I feel people who most come out to me
but the office our 15 year olds who
couldn't have watched the show what
Evers came on so it's I think it's
really big with young people now I think
so which is nice yeah this whole Netflix
thing it's in Amazon both very popular
yeah before I run out of time I'm on my
last question if you could tease a
little bit I'm really looking forward to
last Christmas I saw some footage at
CinemaCon and it looks great and also
I'm really looking forward to I believe
it's Four Weddings and a funeral sure
yes teas um well you know it's a
Christmas dramatic comedy with romance
in it dramatic romantic comedy
everything everything at Christmas time
Christmas time and unreleased George
Michael the Lord of an unreleased George
Michael George Michael song last
Christmas and a lot of fairy lights if
you like fairy lights you're not going
to be disappointed mmm-hmm and for
weddings well it's we took a movie that
is perfect and needs no more sequel
izing or anything and it was a it's a
miniseries with a cast that looks like a
cast I would really want to see a
British Pakistani man and an African
American girl meeting each other in
London but the themes of the Richard
curtis's amazing movie are are present
in the miniseries I think it's great
coming out in a month thank you so much
time seriously congrats on the movie
thank you thank you